thursday pft ot still in chicago we'll
be here tomorrow as well apparently
there is a joint chris sims unbuttoned
the pftpm coming from here tomorrow
before we leave full week one preview
they're really making us work tomorrow
week one preview we're going to pick
games against each other i hope we can
keep that kind of a running tally for
the year too so we can uh have a little
fun there well all my picks will be
published at pft earlier today so you'll
know what mine are in advance i probably
won't i promise you i won't look you
don't go you don't go to the side i
don't act like you do well no i go to
your site all the time don't say that i
always have been you jerk well don't go
don't go today i don't like that one not
that it's going to matter anyways i mean
usually when i pick your picks i go oh
what an idiot this guy is i wouldn't
done that we have started to really
harmonize on things though that is
concerning me it is that really is
concerning me yes we'll see we'll see
what our picks are tomorrow on pftpm and
chris sims unbuttoned for now though a
few things to get to to wrap up thursday
and get you ready for tonight's game we
talked about the packers bears pick we
both like the bears and based on the
score we selected for the game we both
like the under yeah 46. right uh i i
could see
look i i never focus
when i'm picking a game on
whether anyone's going to read into that
for the purposes of over under i could
see it going over yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if it goes over especially
week one so much uncertainty about the
offense you're exactly right to so much
uncertainty about offenses different
game plans guys not being in you know
true game shape yet because they didn't
play a lot through the preseason you
know coaches doing things that you know
the other team just was totally shocked
by or unaware wow you know chuck
pagano's never done this before matt
lefore i've never seen him do this in
their study so you're right i would be
very
careful about betting anything in week
one in the nfl right now i just don't
really i understand that people bet the
over under i don't get enjoyment out of
that and big cat is big on betting the
over yeah it's just a warped way to
watch the game like you're not rooting
for anything other than as many points
as possible
and i it's just i don't know i i don't i
don't bet anyway so i don't have to
worry about it but i don't like to pay
attention to the over under i just pick
the score and if it goes over it goes
over if it doesn't it doesn't but but
for this purpose we wanted to let you
have our thoughts on it we both think
there's a chance it could go over well
you picked 23-16 right yes you're going
bears 23-60 that's 39. so that's just
one touchdown away right i'm going 24-20
so i'm only a field goal away from
changing it there uh but yeah i think i
err on the under more than anything
because i think the defenses in this
matchup are elite or certainly stronger
than the offensive side of the ball and
uh i think that's why i think i would
edge on the the under and sometimes that
first game of the season it's such an
extended feeling out process that it
ends up being sluggish and slow right
and just unsatisfying so there's a
chance that'll happen as well all right
uh speaking generally of the whole over
under concept something to keep in mind
that that i hadn't thought of until
somebody mentioned it yesterday and
we'll we'll leave names out of it for
now but for the purposes of anyone who's
out there in a state where gambling is
legal i wasn't aware of the dynamic that
week one
second half of the games the over
because you can bet pretty much
throughout the game any time but for the
second half whatever the owner is in the
game the over hits far more often than
the under because defensive players are
tired yes and the other dynamics of not
being familiar with the offense and
maybe it's a little harder to make
adjustments you get into a better groove
of making defensive adjustments later in
the season and uh i i wasn't aware of
that but it's something to keep in mind
again if you're in one of the
jurisdictions where that sort of thing
is legal and you're inclined to bet on
the second half over under apparently
the over is a very strong trend i i was
shocked to hear that too it makes sense
in a lot of ways and i think it makes
more sense you know right now with the
current state of the nfl and the fact
that you know we're not seeing teams
play in the preseason they're not
playing their starters yeah there's two
things and you hit on one of them
certainly you've actually hit on even
the other one a segment ago defenses are
not in shape corners get tired pass rush
dies out quarterback has all day to
throw and dissected defense so that
would lead to more points and then the
other thing is you kind of just
mentioned it when we talk about the over
under the the offenses are playing it
careful or close to the vest maybe after
the first drive where they've gotten
their you know first 10 plays and here's
our place to trick them and we look but
after that
they do get conservative in first game
because you start to worry about oh
they're doing this on defense let me
just go with a play that i feel is
all-purpose and simple and our guys have
a great feel to how to execute it it's
not reinventing the wheel to where yeah
things can kind of become kind of boring
like we saw from the packers last year
in week one i know rogers got hurt but
they were kind of sluggish even with
rogers in there early on in the game
second half oh this is what the bears
are doing to attack us and all of a
sudden the game just like went crazy and
roger started throwing lasers all over
the place but a very interesting thing
that i never thought about but i could
see that being a very real dynamic but i
could see offenses being less inclined
to take risks especially in high profile
prime time games week one because it's
the first week it's the first experience
with football since the super bowl and
we're not going to go out there and do
something crazy and run the risk of
being criticized and more intensely than
you would be if you would do something
like that in the middle of the season
when there isn't as much focus because
the first week back there's so much
extra focus yes well and i i think
you're right about that especially early
second half what can lead to other like
teams you know the second half overs oh
the bears are up by two touchdowns to
start the second half now we go oh gosh
green bay's gonna have to throw the ball
and come back and do that and all of a
sudden points start to you know
accumulate on the board and now oh gosh
now the game's a three-point lead by the
bears the bears start to open it up
again so i think those are little things
to look out for interesting i'm gonna i
feel like i'm gonna learn a lot about
betting this year because i don't bet
either i emotionally get invested in the
games very easily i don't need money on
the line uh but i feel like i've had a
lot of people say some smart things to
me lately about betting that i never
thought i'm the same way i don't need it
to enjoy the game and i also get no
enjoyment out of putting my hard-earned
money on the line in anything right like
i'm very averse to buying stocks
anything that feels like i'm putting the
money that i busted my ass to make it
risk i don't like doing it right and and
losing it's like why bill parcells got
out of coaching losing hurts more than
winning feels good no doubt right and i
think if i would gamble when i'd win i'd
be like okay when i'd lose it would
torment me for weeks yeah i'm with you
i've been a few times when my career got
over and i had a few friends who uh
liked to bet they'd always ask me you
know what do you think about this
matchup that matchup and everything and
they bet the opposite and i started yeah
it depends sometimes i got on fire
sometimes they were like the hell with
you i'm going the opposite
uh all right when the falcons start
their season on sunday they'll be in
minnesota julio jones will be on the
field the question is will he have a new
contract and i look michael thomas set
the bar at close to 20 million per year
but not quite 20 million just shy of 20.
yeah
yeah
how much do you think julio jones is
going to get i don't know here i mean
this is i mean he's obviously going to
get a new contract we're hearing about
you know the falcons restructuring deals
and doing things like that with jake
matthews and and trying to free up a
little bit more money i mean
okay he's got two years left on his deal
right his his current deal uh are they
going to i do you think they're going to
one up michael thomas do you think
that's the goal is to make the highest
absolutely period he'll be the highest
paid receiver and i don't think
i don't know yeah but i don't think it's
going to be a little click i think it's
going to be you think it's going to be a
significant pushing in the bar so like
right now michael thomas is that i don't
know
i think you think i think yeah but when
you think you know a lot of times i
don't know what you're talking about
yeah well you're you're you're connected
to the right people in these
conversations
so michael thomas at 19.2 right now
you're saying julio is going to go like
20.2 maybe 21 something like that maybe
higher oh gosh damn you got a real good
tell here no i don't i'm just saying
it's it's a fascinating question it is
something to keep an eye on as the
weekend rolls around we're getting
closer and closer to the point where
these deals are either going to get done
or they're not going to get done and the
julio jones deal is going to get done
the question is how much is it going to
be and i think it's going to be years
how much of a big blow is it going to be
to the salary this is a team that's thin
and not deep already
there's a belief out there that the new
julio jones contract is going to create
cap space i think just because we're
conditioned to assume that that's
they're not doing this
to create cav space they're doing this
to placate the player they've been
creating cap space elsewhere to get this
deal done they're not trying to reduce
the cap number that's what this is about
right this is about paying julio jones
what he deserves as the best receiver in
the nfl and i think the cap number may
go up yeah bottom line is the average is
going to go up he's going to be the
highest paid receiver in the nfl the
question is by how much and my only
point is don't be surprised if it's
significant and i'm not going to be mad
about it i mean he's certainly in that
conversation and certainly deserves to
be paid like the highest guy i mean
right now he's grossly underpaid what is
he at about the eleventh highest paid
receiving 15 million a year something
like that that's right
and i think what really started
and you locked on to this when it all
came up
when he got to the point where matt ryan
is making 30 million a year and he's
making 15. it's like something's wrong
with his picture no doubt about that and
i got to get mine right and and and he's
tried and he's tried he's been patient
he hasn't held out right he did he was
almost last year he was almost going to
hold out his training camp last year and
got a little sweet they moved some money
around but he's there and he's trusted
that arthur blank the owner of the team
is going to make good on the promise to
get him the contract and he's probably
going to get it the next day or so yeah
all right how about this for ryan
fitzpatrick when he starts
for the dolphins this weekend he will be
the first quarterback to start for eight
different teams amazing eight different
teams yeah his first start
the other players with him in the huddle
were marshall faulk torrey holt isaac
bruce and he was sacked by sean taylor
yeah during his first nfl session that's
insane that really is i mean yes it's a
credit to him for the fact that he's
hung around the nfl this long and
survived you know it shows you again
it's kind of like that fine line he's a
great backup but a really low end
starter in the nfl and teams in
transition like guys like ryan
fitzpatrick oh he's smart he's got to
play a lot so we can trust him in
certain situations and that and that
aspect uh he's also gotten lucky in a
number of scenarios where you know you
look good and go he's clearly going to
be the backup and then somebody gets
hurt or gino smith gets punched in the
face by a teammate and all of a sudden
he's a starter so you know i say it all
the time he's irish ryan fitzpatrick of
course he's got he got a shamrock up his
butt when it comes to some of that stuff
uh but either way you know he's done
some good things in the league and you
know it's he's not the guy you want to
run into the future with but but he's a
guy to kind of put a band-aid on the
situation for the for the short time
being he's just got that strange dynamic
where every time we think he's good he
goes the other way and when we assume
he's bad he goes the other way and
eventually i think josh rosen's going to
be playing because even if he starts off
strong and surprises the
the uh ravens the same way that the
buccaneers surprised the saints week one
last year it's going to eventually peter
out and one of the reasons that i love
ryan fitzpatrick he found out on
september 1 2007 that he was being
traded by the rams to the bengals not
from anyone with the rams or anyone with
the bengals he found out about it by
logging on to pro football talk.com
that's how he found out he's amazing
yeah so uh wild stuff and i can't
believe it's been that long ago but he's
been around a long time and he is still
going strong all right next up on the
docket for today
the colts
confirmed
to the indianapolis star and both the
forbes on wednesday
that there was an offer made to purchase
the team of 3.2 billion dollars and jim
irsay rejected it now they haven't
identified whoever made the offer
and i've got two theories okay i'd like
to hear that all right and i want you to
know which way you land okay first
theory is
because they say the team isn't for sale
that's part of this right rejected 3.2
billion offer the team isn't for sale
first theory the team is for sale and
the floor is 3.2 billion gotcha okay
right second theory and this is kind of
like petty
take out a sharpie theory i got to be
careful but um
that forbes came out yesterday with its
valuation of the franchises at 2.6
billion yeah right right and he hey oh
this team's worth more than 2.6 billion
right somebody offered me 3.2 billion
and i said no even if
that offer was never made yes i could
see
jim irsay doing that because he's pissed
off that he's middle of the pack lower
middle of the pack 2.6 billion here the
cowboys at 5.5 billion how dare you my
team's worth more than that my team's
worth three point do i'll give you
evidence but i i was offered 3.2 and i
said no yeah so which one do you think
it is
is the team for sale or is he just
trying to pump up the perceived value i
think it's the perceived value of the
team the first thing i thought of was
like was this something like the owners
talked about and like was this like a
coup d'etat to go like no i was offered
3.2 billion yeah we're all worth more
than than what forbes says or whatever
else it is out there i mean i don't know
what's the point of putting this out
there in general that's where i guess if
you're if you want to sell the team for
more than 3.2 billion that's one reason
to put it i mean the carolina panthers
set their record right 2.3 2.3 billion
so here's he got offered a billion
dollars more 900 million more basically
i i i don't know i just i can't imagine
that that's true i feel like we would
have heard names or somebody along
connected to this situation i feel like
it is a little bit of a maybe a
propaganda to just prop up the franchise
a little bit but i have no idea what
what the deal is here and look the
bottom line is
anything is worth whatever someone will
pay for it if the seller will sell it
and it doesn't like the cowboys they're
worth 5.5 billion well you know what
jerry jones is never going to sell that
team for 5.5 billion but the thing to
keep in mind is this as the franchise
values go up and up and up it is going
to be harder and harder for the families
that own these teams to be able to
continue to own them because there's an
estate tax obligation that kicks in when
that equity is handed down so you gotta
have enough extra cash right to pay that
because now you're gonna sell part of
the t and some i guess some you sell
partners yeah some have had to sell all
of the team to pay the estate taxes but
at some point
the value is going to be so high that
there's not going to be enough human
beings with enough money to own the
teams and they're going to have to
figure out whether they drop the minimum
percentage that's required at some point
do they go to corporate ownership i mean
this is down the road but not all that
far down the road because these
franchise values keep going up and up
and up and up yeah well it's the nfl
it's kicking butt and it's just a
money-making machine at this point and
yeah i mean again with new stadiums
teams building new facilities the tv
packages everything that goes along with
it i mean the nfl franchises of course
are king in this country but yeah i
thought this was a little little i was a
little curious to what your thoughts
were in general uh and yeah i i lean i i
lean towards the we're propping it up
for my own benefit of what i think the
price of the team is and and all nfl
because here's the thing if you're out
there with 3.2 billion dollars and you
want to buy a team you don't quietly go
to jim irsay and say i want to buy your
team for 3.2 billion you hold a press
conference and you say i got 3.2 billion
dollars and whoever wants to sell me
their team give me a call that's that's
where i would that's my point when i was
saying i just i have a hard time feeling
we wouldn't have heard a name from a
schefter a mortenson you somebody out
there right including you yeah you're
kind of in their class either way but so
yeah i was i was just shocked usually
you kind of hear little inklings or
rumors about who might be associated
with that type of offer all right we
wrap up with this marshawn lynch out of
football for now but if he were
commissioner of the nfl you would maybe
come out of retirement because his first
order of business would be legalizing
dodie is dodie the right pronunciation
what is it dodai i don't even know
that's slang for marijuana yeah no i
mean has you ever heard of dodie before
i actually can't say i don't know
is it is it with the young kids i knew
what dodie was i mean i've heard reefer
and things like that reefers like really
that's like the stuff my dad would say
to me he's like are you back there
smoking reaper
that's what he might and the answer
it usually does but
i of course am in favor of this yes i am
i mean first off we're you know i will
always argue for the legalization of
marijuana as long as alcohol is legal
when alcohol is killing people all over
the world drunk you know drunk driving
accidents the number one cause of heart
disease in the world is alcohol there's
so many issues that are associated with
health problems that go along with it
i'm not saying marijuana is the best for
you but as long as that's legal then
marijuana needs to be illegal too and
especially in the nfl because guys do
get addicted to opioids that we talked
about so much i know i had teammates
that battled with that and they
certainly would have rather oh i wish i
could smoke weed and do that to take the
edge off instead of taking vicodin or
doing something like that it's totally
messing up my stomach my system the
chemistry of my brain all of those
things are concerning and i think the
nfl is losing good players over the fact
that they're they're so stringent on
their testing of marijuana too it needs
to change and i do wish america would
legalize it completely just remember
illinois is not weed legal yet
we want you to show up at the stadium
tonight that would make for an awkward
pregame yeah it would be chris is not
here
that chris is locked up
all right
he was smoking reefer uh we're done for
today we'll be back tomorrow but check
us out tonight for the pregame show we
can't wait for the start of the season
we appreciate you sticking with us all
off season long we're going to be here i
mean the best thing about doing this
show during football season we never
have to scramble oh my god tomorrow
we're gonna be able to talk football
it's gonna be football and it's gonna be
getting ready yeah for week one we'll be
back tomorrow everybody have a great day
enjoy the games and we'll see you friday
see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports